per ventura con medie né in tornato 4
milioni e mezzo di iscritti solo al suo
canale video con 15 milioni di click
ma lui ancora si emoziona lo sguardo di
una sola persona l'emozione sta nel
momento in cui una persona mi dicono ma
va a cagare va bene a tutti i ragazzi e
che minuti a questo nuovo sono fa vj
oggi sono con il latte
stamattina a registrare come lo sabato
scorso l'altro questo sabato novità
incredibile armani chi sta lavorando per
creare le nuove felpe le nuove maglie
stiamo lavorando in atto da mesi sta
roba perché vogliamo trovare la maglia
fatta bene quindi di cotone la stampa
giusta ci stiamo lavorando abbiamo
contattato tutte le aziende possibili
per trovare la migliore e tra poco le
distribuiamo così il nuovo logo
diventerà worldwide e chiuderemo tutti i
negozi di vestiti perché la moda
diventerà questa già contattato cara
delle vigne che mi fa lo shooting
comunque ragazzi del video di oggi ho
voluto fare un qualcosa di particolare
vi ho chiesto ieri di mandarmi un vocale
dicendo una frase in dialetto nel
dialetto vostro il mio obiettivo sarà
quello di tradurre questa frase cercare
di capire che cosa avete detto prima
vocale di oggi dialetto ferrarese vado a
cancia età criterium parti una canna
gialla e attaccati al termo non lo so
credo questo la frangia vuol dire
costruisciti nel caso di ghiaccio è
finito e multi fon.ter volo azzeccato
già non saprei tradurre tipo ho fame
figurati na roba così siciliano diavolo
siciliano non decolla il pp narrato che
tela capitando in sardegna the sun
timone che se la casa nostro signore
perché la preghiera la metto la lam
bettona e che ne so la button a peppino
al razzo che tela caso il campinato san
pietro la casa di sant'ignazio ne è
attesa al timone che se la casa nostro
signore santo ignazio santo muore
questa è la casa del nostro signore cosa
lampi e tuoni allontanatevi questa la
casa di campigna campigna the sun timone
questa è la casa di nostro figlio
ragazzo sta al timone jack sparrow
ignazio sparrow la button ha in realtà
voleva dire lampi e tuoni allontanati
l'ampia tonia allontanate io la button
ha più o meno dialetto trentino
attenzione niente potente
cosa sente gas mente potente cosa sente
mentre non hanno capito niente di quello
che ho detto andiamo ore siamo cosa
facciamo hai detto niente non andiamo
dialetto ferrarese ma mi chiama tutti di
ferrara mi mandano invocati oggi magari
ferrara 2.0 a onore
allora la frase in dialetto è fatto una
caccia e paga eterno nov andate a cagare
rivolte i ferraresi questa insomma ma
ferrara ci avete solo sta frase come
dialetto o il resto italiano puro cioè
la frase dialetto è solo questo esiste
non ce ne sono altre let's go for
mantovano regala al dialetto è fanini
famigliari gli soffiò danny minini
dignità anni fa mi ami ami a ripa dul
molto vivo di ogni minima che quando
ricevi un invito è come se dicessi beh
sì potrei venire ma se non vengo sarà
per la prossima volta
ah ok quindi io mi immagino che fai
chiamate voi tre amici le vuoi venire
alla festa ci pensa quando bevono che
casino vialetto varese the bay l'estate
bere berbere ei loro e sinti qui mica
che stai al microfono professionale
regali ma doma ci fa facendo estito in
cui woods paravidino pagliacci ma avati
in ad ora fortunatamente mia nonna era
pugliese quindi grazie a dio
almeno questo l'ho capito solo questo
perché tutto il resto non capisco una
sega ma almeno al bar e grazie a dio al
varese come sai come stai vestito sembra
un pagliaccio una roba leggera ma come
va vestito quello lì sembra un
pagliaccio questa era easy a napoli da
eto'o va vicina luce dramma di malati
futura pac amava 8 watt uscita luce
dramma di marrakech futuro madonna non
capisco niente ora possibile ma dal ha
detto fatto l'ho capito non lo so una
idea di dello scoiattolo di scivolano
dammi tempo che diano la colpa non era
neanche detto fatto di berlusconi
garantisce lo scoiattolo aveva detto
fatto e tu antonella vocali marchigiano
attenzione a the mafia dle a sgrigna
de mattia gola sgrigna tradotto in
italiano adesso ne ha preso la ridarella
a scrigna sarebbe la ridarella ma mai
avere indovinato napoletano per corte
che te le gare coppa batte stata court
immagino tutti i napoletani che stanno
ridendo in questo momento perché sanno
benissimo cosa vuol dire mai non sono
mai proprio niente lunga però stata
accolta solo vuol dire stare attento
almeno quello del 50 per cento da età e
attento che cade giù una cosa del tacca
di joe next o tarantino grazie a dio
veit quentin damascena ma se non si sa
mai se non lo sapete ma così scelta ma
c'è sums non si sa mai se non nella
vicenda se dobbiamo andare andiamo se
non dobbiamo andare andiamoci è una roba
del genere sempre perché pugliese è più
o meno riesca a intuire se dobbiamo
andare andiamoci dobbiamo andare non
andiamo così cazzo così grazie nonna
grazie o part mito ho tradotto l'arabo
porca vacca e sarà una delle più
difficili di oggi a discapito di tutti
lo tradotta non lo è adesso guarda
madonna che youtuber che aiuti quanto
mele merito sti 4 milioni iscritti ma
scelta ma se non riusciamo a se non lo
siamo stati
cioè uno normale come faccio a tradurlo
c'era la mia nonna mi hanno dialetto
pesarese e da una schiappa che perde
trattato dai miei cercate da uno
schiaffo che per che per ritrovarti dove
li va a cercare vedo ti do uno schiaffo
che per d'arte l'altrove niente cerca
per darti l'altro è la tua dai 90 per
cento dialetto fa business al pavia sono
sarà capital qualcosa però questi legale
pavel che era come quella milanese o al
cambio che scrivergli alle pavese dove
sono più o meno
conosco cioè stato con una ragazza di
pavia una volta quindi sei più o meno si
la sciura che si vuol dire questo
quadretto paese che tipo quello similia
paolo di milano per quello di pavia
fiume ha detto siciliano e un po volgare
però è racchiusa in un pilot di schick
con carri il bue va bene in testa parla
con maschio e anche se non volessi
sentirle queste frasi nel da piccolo
sentita a prescindere tira più un pelo
di fa vj che un carro di buoi sicilia
sicilia è pieno rega ha visto un euro di
tutti i domini it has turistiche suoi
deliri a terra bellissima se avessi un
euro per tutte le volte che ho visto il
tuo video a quest'ora avrei più soldi di
dio dove episodi io avessi un euro per
tutti i tuoi video che ho visto a
quest'ora avere più stabilità di montese
io che sono del piemonte ho azzeccato
già due pugliesi non è possibile che non
azzecchi il dialetto da dove sono
arrivato io vai piemontese tra la casa
pensa con lena case sansa lanterna non
ho capito un cazzo e io sono piemontese
il problema è un problema regalo un
capito niente di colore ha detto una
casa pensa a una donna come una casa
senza lanterna dialetto di sassari ma di
una minima e sabattini rapita ray gioco
si fa perché vi mangiare una pizza
vedrai che io non lo so parlare però
vuol dire no tante famiglie
mi fa né si sta per la bocca dello
stomaco quindi temyat piccoli greca e ci
ho azzeccato molisano o vai molise vai a
youtube gambara brook la questa frase
non esiste come la vostra regione non fa
più ridere parlare del molise che non
esisteva e quindi non ne parliamo che
non esiste però non si capisce comunque
un cazzo il core troupe un bar agip club
non capisco niente rega non capisco una
sega andare con lo zoppo impara a
buttare
con pietro impari a pietrare o
piemontese della val di susa 6 torinese
se sbagli a dio patria
qui a lei kulik a la caga dare kula
culona la hall e culi cala q la calotta
russa sicura di non aver dei problemi
non ho capi ma non solo non ho capito un
cazzo sicuro che hai dentro ma proprio
mi sembra pure strano quello che hai
detto
qui a lech ulica la caga dare kula
culona la alle kulik a la q la calotta
russa a calotta russa l'ho capito questo
non è il linguaggio degli un palumba ma
stai scherzando che è quello lega ha
pagato dietro quella colonna la è quello
lì che acqua il cappello rosso
certo che sì spiega mi quando mai uno
che abita in val di susa potrebbe mai
utilizzare questa frase del cagare un
nuovo il cappello rosso dietro una
colonna per sposarla in che contesto la
musicista frase non esiste dialetto
veneto il parte bestemmi on the road e
vorrebbe censurare quindi veneti easy a
chi troppo stretti reinvio fini se
qualcuno invio di troppo si tira
indietro finisce col culo per terra
immagino chi si tira troppo indietro
finisce col culo a molla a mollo ma di
tutti la parola ma ti pare ormai bologna
febbraio a vogue kaki piova tal big
match esce nulla significa vado a casa
che piove te lo dico io ai ragazzi basta
io direi che possiamo concludere quando
ho ascoltato in miliardo oggi a penserò
tutto in dialetto non capito più niente
spero che vi piacciono questi video dove
interagisco con voi a livello vocale
mi diverte un sacco a registrare le cose
e mi piace anche ai social comino torna
letizia rischiate 20 ci vediamo al
prossimo vita da ragazzi
[Musica]